[Music]
hello dear friends Welcome to our
question and answer program here at
secret Sun sealed I'd like to know as I
travel
everybody tells me that their favorite
program is I'd like to know we thank you
for joining us today we have several
really really interesting questions if
you want to send us questions let me
give you the address it'll be on the
screen
TVM tv.org once again TVM
tv.org I just want to underline that the
reason why we do not do this program
live is because when we get the question
uh we don't have the opportunity to
really sit down reflect on it do
research to give a full answer uh we
just would have to answer off the top of
our heads basically but uh we want to do
the research and we want to be thorough
in our answer of the questions I have
with me Pastor David Salasar who is in
charge of our Latino work here at
Secrets unsealed thank you for being
here Pastor it's always a privilege to
serve with you and of course uh before
we begin to answer the questions we need
to ask the Lord for divine wisdom
absolutely so if you would PR please
pray for us
absolutely Heavenly Father once again we
come before your throne of grace and we
humbly submit to your will and ask that
you will give a portion of your holy
spirit so that we may receive the
instruction from above from your throne
of grace and that we may have the right
Enlightenment the right understanding in
of the scriptures so that we may be able
to share to those who are watching not
our own words not our own thoughts but
the Sanctified thoughts that come from
your word we pray that you will help us
today as we share May once again your
name be glorified and we pray this in
Jesus holy name amen
amen all right Pastor uh we have a very
interesting question actually there's a
couple of questions M sent by Diane once
again we don't have a location where the
question is coming from I sure wish that
everybody would send us uh information
on where they're contacting us from uh
because it would be a great blessing to
know what our reach is absolutely uh the
question is will the 144,000 be the only
saved ones alive when Jesus
returns uh and then a sub question what
about the great multitude are they saved
will they see Jesus coming in the clouds
but not be part of the 144,000 that's
the first question several questions
within one uh so what can we say about
the
144,000 um are they the only ones who
are going to be alive when Jesus comes
and how does the great multitude relate
to them it's a good question pastor and
one that certainly needs to be answered
uh we know that the4
144,000 that are mentioned in the Book
of Revelation and we have you know two
chapters that really deal with 104,000
and uh but I'll just go to the chapter
14 where it speaks there in regards to
the the experience of these individuals
and uh it mentions there in in I will
read verses one through three uh or
through four actually so we can actually
look at the information of who they are
uh it says there Revelation 14 verses 1
through uh through five I'll read them
all five it says then I looked and
behold a lamb standing on Mount Zion and
with him 144,000 having his father's
name green on their foreheads and I
Heard a Voice from heaven like the voice
of many Waters and like the voice of a
loud thunder and I heard the sound of
the harpes playing the harps and they
sang as it were a new song Before the
Throne before the four living creatures
and the elders and no one could learn
that song except the 144,000 who redeem
from the earth these are the ones who
were not defiled with wom for they are
virgins these are the ones who follow
the lamb wherever he goes these were
redeemed from among men being first
fruits to God and to the lamb and in
their mouth was found no Gile for they
without fall Before the Throne of God so
here in these few verses we see this is
a specific group of individuals it's a
specific number of individuals is not
necessarily defining uh yet the you know
whether it is a literal or or symbolic
number just giving us a definition that
this is a group of people that have have
who have an unique experience and spirit
prophecy mentions in you know great
controversy in regards to them the
following I will read briefly from great
controversy page 648 649 they sing a new
song as we just read verse three Before
the Throne a song which no man can learn
save the 144,000 it is a song of Moses
and the lamb a song of Deliverance none
but the 144,000 can learn that song for
it is a song of their experience an
experience such as no other company have
ever had these are they which follow the
lamb whever so he goeth these having
been translated from the Earth from
among the living from among the living
she says are counted as the first fruits
unto God and to the lamb these are they
which came out of a Great Tribulation of
the Great Tribulation they have passed
through the time of trouble such as
never was see there was a nation they
have endured the anguish of a time of
Jacob's trouble they have stood without
an intercessor through the final
outpouring of God's judgments so this is
what makes them the unique group the one
that can sing that unique song that only
them can sing and so these are
definitely the ones that are remaining
alive till the very end till Christ
comes so will they be the only ones
alive I will say this way they will be
the only ones that have not tasted death
right you know that's the key they have
not taste the death until Christ comes
they have gone through a time of trouble
they have lived without an intercessor
that makes them unique now uh I think
that you could add and you probably
going to answer you know more things
about this but I wanted to make that
point about them they are the ones that
have not tasted death they have not seen
death they have have Victory with Christ
throughout the experience until Christ
comes yeah absolutely I agree 100% uh
and it was a good good answer because it
gives several several characteristics
there that Ellen White presents in great
controversy 648 and 649 right uh it's
not only one or two things it's many uh
if you continue reading it says that
they've lived During the period of the
plagues MH uh you know they uh and yet
they were victorious right uh there's
another passage in Revelation which
doesn't mention 144,000 but you we know
that it's talking about the 144,000
correct um and that's in chapter 15 this
tells us when they actually lived
chapter
15 it says in uh verse two and I saw
something like a sea of glass mingled
with fire and those who have the victory
over the Beast mhm over his image and
over his Mark and over the number of his
name standing on the sea of glass having
harps of God yeah that's set of the
144,000 in chapter 14 and some of the
details in chapter 7 correct so clearly
this is the last generation mhm because
it tells us that they gained the victory
over the
Beast over his image image over his Mark
and his name none of those things
existed during the times of Martin
Luther yeah exactly or the Apostle
Paul those are
characteristics the image has not even
been raised up yet mhm and the Mark has
not been imposed yet correct the 144,000
are actually going to face the beast's
image and his Mark and they're going to
be faithful they're the end time
generation those who will go
victoriously through the final time of
trouble amen now in regards to the
question that she mentions will they be
the only save ones alive um it's it's
important to know that before Christ
comes right before his coming uh the
time when the Lord declares you know the
it is finished In Heaven There is what
it will become and you're going to proba
explain this better in the next question
because she's asking about the state of
you know of of the events the final
events but there is this special
resurrection that happens and in that
special Resurrection there is a
resurrection of some who were not able
to
experience you know the the the plagues
and not were not alive when they had to
go through the tribulation but because
they preached and they lived the message
of the Three Angels message they will be
resurrected as well to see Jesus come in
glory yeah so they will not be I mean
104,000 the ones that don't see death
are not going to be the only ones seeing
the Lord appearing it will also be those
that pierce Christ and those who are
resurrected in the in the special
Resurrection that's kind of like a
preview of the main first resurrection
that will happen when Christ comes so
these are those that join with 104,000
and they see the last final things of
God's uh you know events if you will you
know the coming of Christ they will see
the whole uh aspect of the commun of
Christ and then uh just because she asks
you know when what about the great
multitude or or or those that are saved
well they will see Jesus when they he
calls his their name and they'll be
gathered from all the corners of the
earth so they will not see the whole
aspect of the coming of Christ they just
see Christ as they are called by name
that's a very very good point that you
make uh that uh there are going to be
two groups that actually see the entire
second coming of Christ right you have
the
144,000 who are changed in a moment in
the twinkling of an eye uh not
resurrected right but glorified MH and
then at that very same moment according
to Great
controversy those who died in the faith
of the third Angel's message will
resurrect at the same moment that the
144,000 are
changed the the living uh the the Dead
who died in the third Angel's message
are also going to receive their
glorified bodies mhm and they will see
the second coming of Christ from
beginning to end right and only when
Jesus is above the Earth at the
conclusion of the second coming will the
rest of the righteous resurrect amen by
the way during this period also those
who Pierce Jesus like you mentioned are
going to be alive to see Jesus coming on
the Clouds Of Heaven so even those who
Pierce Christ are going to see the
entire second coming of Christ
absolutely and this is where you know
all the redeemed I mean all the ones who
have confessed of Christ who are written
in the book of life will be resurrected
and they all will be saved and um this
is you know I mean there's a little bit
of of I guess of a confusion or debate
you know whether the great multitude
it's it's really you know everybody
that's saved or is 14,000 uh I think you
have a better um understanding of our a
good you know topic on this thing but
ultimately the main thing to to point
out in this program is that all you know
the number of redeemed is a number that
can no man can count says the word of
God you know there's there's thousands
upon thousands of people who are
redeemed who will be resurrected when
Christ comes throughout history and so
of course all of the the ones that are
written in the Book of Life will have
will be saved and will see Jesus at that
moment in The Cloud of Glory when they
are called to to to be picked up by the
Angels around the whole world
with regards to the great multitude
there are two main views uh in the
Adventist Church right number one is the
great multitude are the redeemed of all
ages and the other is that the great
multitude is the same group as
144,000 only uh after they're
victorious in other words uh um the
144,000 is a symbolic number MH of those
who are alive the great multitude
indicates that the number 144,000 is not
a literal number it's composed of many
many people right beyond the number
144,000 um in the studies that I have
done and shared I believe that the
144,000 and the great multitude are the
same group the 144,000 that are sealed
are about to go into the tribulation
whereas the great multitude are the same
group coming out of the Great
Tribulation and one of the things that
led me to to think this is that um
um the
144,000 uh it says are the only ones
that are able to enter the temple
mhm however uh the great multitude
according to Revelation 7 serves God in
his Temple day and night right so if the
144,000 are the only ones that can enter
the temple but the great multitude
serves God days and night day and night
in his Temple
they must be the same group right
another reason is that in that statement
that you read from great controversy 648
and
649 Ellen White in describing the
144,000 intermingles texts that speak
about the great multitude right uh so
she seems to indicate that they they are
the same group um this they're
sealed 144,000 sealed before they enter
the Great Tribulation and then the great
multitude who comes out of the Great
Tribulation because that Revelation 7
says that these have come out of Great
Tribulation M uh so anyway that's the
answer that we can provide for the first
uh question the second question is can
you speak to the order of events between
now and the return of Jesus uh so so
what can we say about the order of
events well Pastor Bor we have you have
had also a a very good detail um Series
in regards to this particular idea which
is found in Matthew 24 Matthew 24 I
believe is the best and plus Christ
himself decare the best explanation of
the sequence of events that will happen
you know well in the case of Jesus from
the time of Christ really but more more
more directly applied to the time in
which we live the last events of of of
that will happen on this world so if you
want to know if you know our friend
Diane wants to know the the sequence of
events we can briefly look into what you
know Jesus mentions in there in Matthew
24 and um we can look uh I think we
probably
start uh from verse 14 and and then
maybe we can just go through some few
verses just to give an idea but verse 14
mentions this and says and this Gospel
of the Kingdom will be preached in all
the world as a witness to All Nations
and then the end will come so that's
sort of the starting point I I think for
us to understand the final events the
the ones that will you know end the
world or end the world as we know will
happen as we start as the gospel is
preached as a witness as a testimony uh
By God's people in this world this is
the beginning of the true riching with
the gospel the true Gospel of the world
of Christ throughout the world but then
we going to go into the experiences of
what will happen in these last days it's
you know then uh we know that the verse
21 speaks of the Great Tribulation that
will start so um I don't know Pastor if
you can take from here and just kind of
go let us see step by step how this goes
through yeah well as I've uh studied in
U Matthew chapter 24 uh you have a
chronological sequence of events mhm uh
maybe I'll just begin with u with the
Great Tribulation which you just
mentioned right uh the Great Tribulation
is the time of Jacob's trouble it's the
great time of trouble after the close of
probation MH uh and then you know uh you
follow along the Great Tribulation is
verse 21 MH and then uh it says that
those days are going to be short and or
else nobody would survive correct it
shows that it's the greatest it's the
greatest in history because it says
there in verse 21 uh Great Tribulation
such as has not been since the beginning
of the world until this time no nor
shall ever be right and we know that
that Great Tribulation is the time of
trouble after the close of probation MH
because there's not going to be any
bigger time of trouble with that one
afterwards and so and then it says in
unless those days were shortened no
flesh would be saved absolutely and then
uh you have the counterfeit Second
Coming the personation of Christ by
Satan right that's verses 2 three uh and
following and uh then of course you have
in verse 29 um the sun being darkened
the Moon being darkened uh the Stars
falling from Heaven other words the
heavens are going to go go dark right uh
and then it says then the sign sign of
the son of man is going to be seen in
heaven right that's the hand about half
the size of the palm of a hand the
little Cloud that becomes bigger and
bigger uh and then when the the sign of
the son of man is seen you have the um
the crying out of the wicked those who
Pierce Christ and the greatest enemies
of the truth and then after that you're
going to have uh the coming of Jesus on
the clouds of heaven and then when he's
above the Earth uh he sends his angels
with the sound of a great trumpet
exactly to pick up the those uh the
elect which represents uh those who went
through the Great Tribulation and also
the resurrection of the righteous so U
those and and then a book of re ation
fills in the gaps correct because
there's things in between this you know
that are Amplified in the book great
controversy and also in the Book of
Revelation correct and you know the
question maybe that Diane may have is
well till that starts what now what
right now we're in time of of of um
probation you know we still have Grace
there uh there is the the next event
that we know will happen is the starting
or setting up of the mark of Beast the
Sunday law so we know that while this
happens we don't know there's not Define
time when that will happen we know that
the close of probation will happen you
know after that final test is given to
all mankind um but until that moment
what we need to do right now is
understand that we're living in the time
of judgment we're living in the time of
the investigative judgment that God is
you know uh giving us his grace of his
of his power to to live lives that are
Sanctified by the influence of the Holy
Spirit and by his grace we can today
elect to live holy lives lives that are
connected with Christ and as we gain the
knowledge and the growth and the victory
over our Temptation or sin we are
preparing ourselves to be able to go
through that time as we mentioned the
Great Tribulation which will be a time
when there will be no intercessors so I
think that is important that today we
take our time to dedicate ourselves to
the study of scriptures to give and
yield our hearts to the Lord and know
that um you know the time of the time of
our test will be very soon how soon we
don't know it could be as soon as this
year maybe many years we don't know that
specifically what we know is that we
have to be ready and be willing to live
according to the will of God in our
lives yeah you know I want to take this
opportunity to to encourage those who
are watching this program to make plans
to attend our U yearly anchor School of
Theology which is in the middle of the
month of March yes uh check it out the
information uh online at our secrets on
seal website uh this is going to be one
of the most important anchors that I've
ever done and I've done many uh over 15
right of the anchors we start on a
Monday and we end on a Sabbath and it's
24 hours of very intensive
teaching and uh my favorite all time is
the Matthew
241 but my second favorite one is the
one that I haven't done
yet the one for anchor this year if you
want to know what awaits us from right
now until uh the second coming of Christ
that would be the particular anchor
School of Theology that they need to
attend right uh this is a unique series
series you know we're going to study
Daniel 2 Daniel 7 Revelation 123 and 17
and I've done individual presentations
on each of those chapters but what makes
this uh series unique the one that we're
going to do in in March is how they are
connected together how Daniel 2 is
expanded in Daniel 7 and Daniel 2 and 7
are expanded in Revelation 12 and I'll
Daniel 2 Daniel 7 Revelation 12 is
expanded in Chapter 13 and the final
expansion in chapter 17 which is a
chapter that is rarely studied uh
because it it appears to be very
complicated the Beast that was and is
not and will be and you know it has
seven heads but there's an eigh head it
seems like there is uh and so it's very
complicated but this is a unique Series
in the sense of the method that I'm
going to use to present the prophecies
so if you really want to understand the
prophecy
the chain Prophecies of Daniel
Revelation I would greatly uh encourage
amen those who are watching this program
to come for that week uh of study very
intensive study uh because it's going to
be very rewarding you will have a clear
picture of where we
are and what awaits us and where we are
going in the course of history it is an
extremely important series and um so I'm
thankful that I was given this little
commercial break time to be able to
promote it it's not because uh you know
we are desperate for you to come
although we really want you to come uh
it's very inexpensive it's I think like
$150 for all of the week of instruction
the 24 hours yeah so please uh join us
for that particular uh anchor School of
Theology check our website you know
Pastor just to just to say this briefly
um young man from Chicago called me just
a couple of days ago 19 years old and he
said pastor I want to study I want to go
to the Anchor class and he he signed up
he's going to come so I know that it's
important for no matter the age to come
and be part of that program amen they're
going to be blessed well thank you so
much for joining us for our program
today for I'd like to know may God bless
you we hope that you'll join us next
time uh please send us your questions
and let us know where they're coming
from God bless and be with you
[Music]